joining us now for more on this and
other political developments let's bring
in our panel gop
pac chairman and gop strategist david
avella and
democratic strategist and fox news
contributor jessica tarloff welcome to
both of you
hello thanks so much what do you
anticipate from this week's confirmation
hearings jessica
and is nira tandon's nomination to be
budget director dead now that west
virginia senator joe manchin says he's a
no on her
well i wouldn't say that it was dead but
it's definitely going to be a little bit
more complicated than democrats had
hoped at the beginning of this
i remember we talked about this when joe
biden put her name out there in the
first place and we thought oh
potentially she could have been the
sacrificial lamb in all of this
because he knew that republicans would
pretend that they cared about her tweets
when they didn't care about president
trump's tweets for
four or five years there so yet to be
seen there but i imagine we could pick
up a republican vote or two and
president biden has said that he still
thinks
that she'll be able to get through
merrick garland's hearing though i'm
really excited
to see because right before mitch well
right after mitch mcconnell said that he
was not going to vote to convict
president trump former president trump
in the impeachment hearing
he did essentially signal to the justice
department hey
this is for you now i don't think that
we have the power to convict him
but you do so it'll be interesting to
see how many republicans especially
those who voted to convict
former president trump kind of egg
merrick garland on about that and want
to talk about how he's going to treat
the former president as well as those
who participated
in the riots on january 6. david what's
your prediction for these upcoming
hearings for some really critical
cabinet spots tandon could be setting
precedent here mike
only four times since 1970
has a majority senate
of the president not confirmed his
nominees
president clinton president bush ii and
president obama all because the nominees
had
tax issues tandon could be the first one
that doesn't get confirmed because of
her
vitriolic messages that she would make
on
twitter and other social media platforms
as she went after
u.s senators and now she's being held
accountable
all even more interesting though is the
fact that we haven't had a
vote on the secretary of education which
arguably is one of the most important
positions right now
as we face uh not getting trying to get
schools open
and i don't know if it's because uh
cardona has expressed an interest in
opening schools and
schumer's putting him on a back burner
but gosh you would have thought he would
have been in the first week of
confirmations
if they truly were trying to get schools
open all right to the scandal in new
york state governor andrew cuomo there's
been use of the i
word impeachment jessica is he in
serious trouble
i do think that he's in serious trouble
i'm not sure if he's going to be
impeached over this or how far
it will go but the fact that we do have
an open investigation now that's been
confirmed
um in new york state and that's so many
people in his own party who serve under
him have come out and spoken out against
him going so far as to say that he's
personally threatened them
like ron kim an assembly member it's
certainly not
a good couple of weeks for the new york
governor
and i wish that he would have months ago
but also even today it would go a long
way to come out
and to talk about what happened and to
offer an apology we are
a forgiving country people know that we
had
frankly no idea what kobot was going to
do how it was working and people made
mistakes like in new jersey governor
phil murphy did exactly the same thing
but he didn't win an emmy for it or
write a book at the same time
and i think that governor cuomo kind of
needs needs to face the public on this
one
yeah you have to show some humility
david your thoughts yet again the
cover-up is always worse than the crime
often and that is what we're seeing here
governor cuomo isn't going to get even
if he is
pushed by the democrats he will
ultimately still be their nominee
which gives a big opening for
republicans as we go into the
2022 election for
us to potentially pick up the
governorship of of new york
next weekend we expect the return of
former president trump
before a friendly uh audience at cpac
jessica your thoughts
i think it's going to be much of the
same it'll be interesting to see
uh how much he stays away though from
talking about
the big lie obviously that he lost that
he actually won the election even though
we know that he lost it but he's clearly
not trying
to talk about dominion or smart tech
because he knows that he could be sued
for that so we noticed that when he
called in
to fox news and went on newsmax and won
america news the day that rush limbaugh
passed away i imagine it'll be much of
the same talking about his record
and then also digging into that fissure
that he's certainly trying to exploit
between his side of the party and the
establishment side of the party he's
already said that he'll go
and campaign for quote maga candidates
who are running against
sitting republicans which is sure to
infuriate mitch mcconnell even further
david i want to play a clip from former
arkansas governor mike huckabee and then
i'll get you to respond
i think the first thing that the
president should say when he gets to the
podium at cpac
is you all miss me yet we miss pro-life
policies we miss
pro-america policies we miss the
pushback against china
rather than surrendering to them we miss
the independence of having an america
that doesn't
surrender to the paris climate accords
and uh that
actually pushes for a realignment of the
middle east
david your thoughts on this appearance
as
mike huckabee said americans 74 million
of them voted for the president trump
because of the agenda that he pursued
this also the president going to
cpac underscores the importance florida
is going to play
in 2024 for the republican nomination i
mean arguably there'll be
there are four republicans looking at it
right now governor
desantis senator scott senator
rubio and former president trump now all
looking at looking making a bid in 2024
it's hard to see someone getting the
nomination and it not going through
florida
and it's underscored by the fact that
president trump's going to cpac
david jessica thanks so much have a
great week